well today one of the strip's oldest
resorts will finally welcome back
customers
it's another sign tourism is starting to
come back to the valley bianca holman is
live on the strip this morning
with what's planned at the tropicana hey
bianca
hey good morning alex this strip
original opened
back in 1957 of course things looked a
lot different there was desert
all around 63 years ago but this
property will be opening
tomorrow to of course it's welcome its
guests and
and like every other resort in nevada
the tropicana shut down mid-march
after the governor ordered them to close
to slow the spread of the coronavirus
while many casinos reopened june 4th
others have been more slow to return the
tropicana had originally set a date of
september first to reopen but that was
ultimately pushed back till
thursday like other big resorts there
are new protocols in place such as
distancing and sanitation live music is
on hold and the gaming floor is limited
to 50 percent capacity
the hotel spa and pool will reopen for
guests all starting
on thursday the 17th now earlier this
week we learned that the park mgm
will be reopening at the end of the
month of course with some changes
it will be a non-smoking property but
there are some other properties on the
strip that have yet to reopen
cromwell and planet hollywood those are
the last two properties on the resort
that have yet to reopen and then also
off the strip the palms the rio
and a handful of other local resorts and
of course lee
hopefully this is a sign of some good
news as properties begin to slowly
reopen
reporting live from near the las vegas
boulevard bianca holman
8 news now